y redescubrir la fraternidad y superar
las divisiones este es el mensaje que el
papa ha querido enviar en el segundo día
de su visita a chipre donde la llegada
de emigrantes ha aumentado un 38% este
año
con la mira puesta en la crisis
migratoria el papá advirtió a los
europeos contra los muros del miedo y
los intereses nacionalistas durante una
gran misa celebrada el viernes en
nicosia ante más de 7000 fieles
también deseo una gestión más humana de
los exiliados así como la ayuda de los
demás miembros de la unión europea
queridos hermanos y hermanas frente a
nuestra propia oscuridad y a los
desafíos que enfrentamos en la iglesia y
en la sociedad que estamos llamados a
renovar nuestro sentido de la
fraternidad si no dialogamos si no
caminamos juntos no podremos hablar
plenamente nuestra senyera ni que no
seamos uady definidamente del cheetah
una fraternidad que el papá ha decidido
expresar acogiendo en el vaticano a 50
migrantes que viajarán junto con la
expedición apostólica tras la visita de
benedicto 16 en 2010 esta es la segunda
visita de un sumo pontífice a la isla
que francisco describe como punto de
encuentro entre oriente y occidente